okay good evening
ladies and gentlemen turned it off and
welcome to tonight's planning committee
as you can see we have a few technical
glitches but i think we're over there
now uh good evening and welcome to
tonight's planet committee meeting my
name is peter richards i will be
chairing this evening's meeting um some
housekeeping to start with we're not
expecting a fire alarm so if one does go
off please follow us out to the car park
next to the pub over the road so we can
take your name off and make sure you're
safe before you head off home um phones
if you could please turn them off at the
very least the silent i don't mind you
using them provided they don't
detract from the flow of the meeting
we are of course being live streamed
and recorded for later use on youtube so
please be aware of that the meeting is a
meeting in public it is not a public
meeting so only those people that have
registered to speak will be permitted to
do so at the appropriate time i will
call you forward to one of the two desks
in front of you there are hand sanitizer
uh gels and desk wipes should you wish
to use them feel free to do so if you
want to um i will then tell you how much
time you have it will typically be three
minutes with a 30 second warning and if
you stay seated for questions afterwards
that would be great
some intros um so to my far right we
have olivia quinn who is our committee
services representative to my immediate
right
no particular order our sebastian onslow
sarah chadwick and stuart flaherty and
to my immediate left is david jeffery
who is our planning manager david i
believe you've got a statement to make
i do thank you chair my name is david
jeffrey my role is to provide impartial
advice and to assist members in their
decision taking thank you
fabulous thank you very much indeed
right let's get into the agenda proper
um apologies for having silver do we
have any apologies please got apologies
from councillor
thank you very much um disclosures of
interest members i'm gonna make a couple
to start with while you think about
yours um so on the first item tpo zero
two five zero one two i am as you will
notice the ward member for that um i'm
here with a completely open mind so i
will remain on the committee for that um
also for the final item of the evening
which is 2201179
ful oak tree farm i've received a series
of emails um which i believe were all
copied into you if you could just
verbally confirm that you have received
those uh so that we can notice that on
the uh disclosure interest that'd be
great so cancer kendall if you
just a quick yes is fine
yes
council crumb
yeah
yes
yes
yes fabulous we will then put that down
as everyone has received the same does
anyone have any others councillor crump
is that not working
is it flashing if you wait until it
finishes flash i think it just needs to
pre-heat so you won't finish the
flashing try again then it should come
on
thank you
item number 22 stroke zero one one seven
nine straight ful
um
i know the applicant and have had
dealings in the past
in my previous role as covering the ward
member for the county council often
and i feel i need to declare an interest
and not take part in that part of the
committee agenda thank you understood
thank you very much councillor dixon
thank you chairman item for which is
zero three application
one six o u t i'm the ward member i've
registered to speak i have no personal
interest in this matter but i will be
speaking on the application
marvelous thank you anyone else with any
other disclosures no marvelous let's
move to our first planning application
then which is um tpo025012
land to north of station road in clavdon
and our presenting officer is sarah
chadwick sarah over to you
thank you chairman
this item relates to tree preservation
order tpo zero twenty five zero one two
the tree is located in to the north of
station road in cleveland and is denoted
by the green circle on the this plan the
site is in the west midlands green belt
and arden special landscape area and
it's located adjacent to the boundary of
the claverden conservation area
indicated here by the pink line on the
plant
the tree preservation order relates to
one
penducular oak tree seen in the images
here which show the tree at different
times of year with the images taken
facing the north east and northwest
respectively
the tree is located to the front of a
former tennis court site the tpo was
served on the tree following a report
that the site had come forward for sale
through auction the change in land
ownership presented a potential threat
to the tree and a temper assessment was
carried out during the officer's site
visit through this assessment officers
determined that the tree accrued enough
points that a tree preservation order
would be defensible and the tpo was
served on the 4th of february 2022
this final image is taken facing in an
easterly direction with station road in
the foreground
chairman members have three options as
to how to determine the order as set out
on page seven of the agenda
for the reason set out in the committee
report it is officer's recommendation to
confirm confirm the order is made thank
you
i'll hand over to sebastian to go
through the tempo assessment criteria
hello
um so the tempo or tree evaluation
method for preservation orders is a
systemized assessment tool for a tree
suitability for a tpo
the tempo is a field guide to decision
making carried out by completing a pro
forma similar to this one i'm holding
here on site during the tree assessment
uh tempo considers factors such as the
tree's visibility and public immunity
value its future retention span
suitability for protection and any
special circumstances scores are awarded
for each section and totaled at the end
the score will determine whether or not
the tpo is defensible this is a widely
recognized method of assessment and
ensures consistency
from accounts perspective when serving
tpos
marvelous thank you um i believe that we
do need an update on the um page six um
just want to confirm that it apparently
it says no structural no significant
structural physiological defects were
identified at the time of the site visit
which could suggest the tree currently
presents a risk to the public highway
i'm assuming that should say does not
present a risk of the public highway
sorry chairman yes that's correct
marvelous thank you very much indeed we
don't have any speakers so members have
you got any questions or points of
clarification
no let's go to debate who'd like it to
kick us off council jennings
okay i think it's important to protect
healthy trees
um it's highly visible
i would simply i'll go straight in here
and like to propose option one to
confirm the order
thank you very much council kendall
uh yeah i'll second that
thank you very much anyone else
let's go to a vote you could have a show
of hands for those in favor of
confirming the order
unanimous jail unanimous marvelous in
that case uh committee resolves to
do i say to grant or is it to confirm
to confirm the tpo has been made
marvelous
will be made
okay let's move on to our next
application which is application
21-0-3-7-1-6-0-u-t
land at ellswood common in earlsword
again our presenting officer is sarah
chadwick sarah whenever you're ready the
floor is yours
thank you chairman
thank you chairman this is an outline
application for the direction of one
self-built dwelling with all matters
reserved except for access
the application site is located on
earthwork common and is denoted by the
red line on this plan
the site is located outside of the drop
build area boundary of ellsworth as
defined in the draft tamworth and arden
neighborhood plan
here we see an indicative proposed site
plan the plan shows an area of
hearthstone to the west of the proposed
running and a new access of ellsworth
common the dwelling would be cited
broadly in line
it with the dwelling to the north
headlands in its indicative location
this slide shows a satellite image of
the site relative to the surrounding
built form with the slight location
indicated by the star in the centre of
the image
this photograph is taken looking into
the site facing towards the southeast
and this photo is taken facing in the
northerly direction along earth were
common with the site located on the
right of the image the property seen to
the right is known as hedgeland amongst
the edge of the draft built up area
boundary of ellswood
chairman the development does not mean
any of the exceptions to inappropriate
development are set out in the mppf as
such the proposal has some conflict with
the development plan however the
shortfall in self and
housing is a material consideration that
is considered to outweigh this
very special circumstances have
therefore been identified and are
considered to outweigh the harm caused
to the greenbelt
it is therefore officer's recommendation
to grant subject to the conditions as
detailed on page 20 at the agenda thank
you
sarah thank you very much we'll move to
our first speak of the evening who is
councillor mike saunders of tamworth on
arden parish council
good evening
now councilman soldiers you're going to
have three minutes um i will give you a
30 second warning before your time is up
um otherwise if you press the button in
the middle on that machine it should
hopefully it will go red
is it flashing
if we if we let it finish flashing i
think we probably needed to warm them up
before we started but it should
hopefully it'll stop flashing and then
you'll be able to press it again it'll
go red
is it red on the base
could you press the middle button again
for me there you go you're on okay so as
soon as you're ready it's over to you
thank you for listening to me
um the case officer makes it quite clear
that this application
leaving aside self-build would be
refused as contrary to green belt policy
the her report does not mention two
things which i think are relevant to
this and they are both in the
site allocation plan
site adaptation man has a section on
self build and two policies
and the policy in respect of unallocated
sites i not allocated by the district
council
is that they should be supported in
principle except in areas covered by the
green belt so quite clearly in that
document you are excluding greenbelt
sites for self-build which are
unannotated
and secondly
it says um
states quite clear regards government
policy however the government does not
expect local authorities to provide such
opportunities for self-build on plots
that would not otherwise be considered
suitable
and in this case this plot would not be
considered suitable because it falls
found the green belt policies
and my last point i want to make is
regard even if none of that were true
and i've got i've misunderstood the
documents
there is no case here for saying
that that strategy counts in such
desperate straits for self-built sites
this one must be granted planning
permission contrary to the greenbelt
policy
as i understand it there's some 880
um registered
interest in self-build
and your site allocation policy has
allocated 136
such sites leaving a side master in a
lighthorn where more into courts will be
found
so i i really don't think that a case
has been made
um
to override the green belt in this
instance
council saunders thank you very much
have you remembered to see if anyone has
a question for you members anyone would
like to answer ask council someone as a
question
i'll take that as a no in that case
council's honors thank you very much
we will move to our next speaker who is
counselor dixon councillor dixon please
do come on down
thank you chairman uh you know the drill
you'll have five minutes with 30 second
warning towards the end feel free to use
as much or as little as that as you wish
whenever you're ready it's over to you
thank you chairman uh i'm glad to see
that uh the map of uh the built-up area
boundary for earlswood from the ndp is
on the screen
i would also point members to it's in
the report tamizawa neighborhood
development plan significant weight now
afforded in decision making significant
it does carry weight
moving through to
the conclusions
like the parish council
this is in the green belt
there are no special circumstances
worthy of the merit
the officer indicates that
the development would not meet any of
the forms of the exceptions to
inappropriate development
it is only possible if there are very
special circumstances
those very special circumstances uh is
deemed by the officer to be a situation
whereby there are
is need for self build or custom build
plots
if we could have a look please at the
actual site plan
there's also a suggestion that the
site
is uh surrounded on three sides um yes
hedgelands is the end of the built-up
area boundary and indeed there is a
property to the south uh the swallow
cottage which is
uh really behind the one that's to the
south of the property is more to the
south east uh those constructions behind
the said plot are in fact barn so
they're not they're not premises and
buildings as such
so i don't think the site is as unique
as the officers would suggest if you
could go back to the slide please of the
ndp that i presented what i have
indicated their members is a situation
whereby at the very south end of the
built-up area boundary which is across
the road from this particular site
is a section of
ellswood
which has properties to the north of it
and properties to the south of it it all
has a road to frontage and
if uh that was subdivided into plots on
the same width as the ribbon development
which is how earl's would uh originally
developed years ago
at 40 uh per
more or less uh plot then essentially
you'd have room for another 10 self
builds all in the green belt this print
this application is all about are we
ready to see the principle of building
in the green belt actually surrendered
i think this application is quite simply
too soon
the core strategy is being reviewed the
south warwickshire local plan is being
formed the green belt will be part and
parcel of those reviews and discussions
but quite simply on there on that plan i
have highlighted uh four areas which are
between
uh built up areas within earlswood earls
would as i say the common ribbon
development when it was developed hasn't
been a lot of uh new building since
1974. obviously there's been
infill within the built-up area boundary
there's been one for one demolition in
rebuild but there hasn't been any
filling in on property on properties
outside of those areas
that
those red areas
as i say on very generous size plots
could actually accommodate i calculated
11 21 25 properties and if the principle
was given away this evening for building
in the green belt then essentially you
would have a big problem
i would uh also mention two members
that we had an appeal review at our last
meeting
there were six decisions which came went
to appeal
four of which came to this committee as
recommendations for grant
we as a committee refused those four and
of those for
only one uh when it went to an
inspection was upheld by the inspector
the other three our decisions were right
the officers recommendations were
regarded as being weak by the inspector
i suggest again to do this evening the
recommendation that
the
provision of self build in the green
belt is insufficient uh to outweigh the
significant harm uh the actual um 30
seconds of the of the officer
that
the harm to the green bait the harm to
the green belt must be given significant
no it's not substantial weight
and she has identified no additional
harm so essentially there's significant
weight there's significant harm
and essentially we should not be sending
a new principle this evening gentlemen
and ladies thank you
ken sixth and thank you very much
members do you have any questions for
our ward member
cancer crump hello councillor dixon um
can you just confirm
you mentioned the ndp um with
substantial right now or work out coming
was it so essential
the officers report indeed
indicates on
page 12
of the material considerations the time
was neighborhood development plan 16 to
31
examiner's report published 28 to
february 22 significant weight afforded
to in decision making yeah i i've had it
i couldn't but then they you can't see
it for looking something i don't know
i apologize for that i knew where it was
um so yeah there's a couple of reasons
for it um
certainly
do you have another question casa crump
so i've got you you've got to start
debating with council dixon
do you have a question i have before if
somebody else wants to speak off i'll
come back does anyone else want to have
a question no council crump
you can ask your question but please
make sure it is a question i wrote it um
and also
um
you're saying that you don't believe
there are the special circumstances
out why
the negative effect on the grain belt is
up correct
essentially the officer's comments are
that
in her view because there are
a few buildings to the south and
southeast and one to the to the north
west
uh that is a unique site
uh i don't think it is unique and i
don't think it is sufficient equally
well
because it's only outlined and in
principle
if it was actually granted i think there
is a fear i know we're only looking at
what we've got tonight that there would
be more than one house put on that plot
there is sufficient size at the back we
do have to focus
cancer dicks i'm going to stop you there
we do have to focus on what we're
looking at tonight what you are starting
to bring in and you did during your
speech as well there's a lot of hearsay
we need to members you need to be
mindful of the fact that we are only
looking at what is in front of us
tonight
i don't think there are any other
questions
no
okay we have no more speakers on this
item so um we will open up for um uh
points clarification to the officers
members council shining straight in
council jennings
have a bit of clarification on exactly
where this is to the the built-up area
boundary because i know you've just seen
a very big map there but it's quite
difficult to pinpoint it in yeah i've
just got a little snippet for two
seconds
so
the property in the photograph my last
photograph is this one if you can see my
cursor it's the one right at the bottom
of the black thick line there to the bab
and then this arrow indicates the site
i'm not sure if it's clear but it's it's
like adjacent to the edge of the bubble
do you have any follow-ups
go ahead
further question um one of the should we
be mindful to to grant this i know
in the condition
that uh it says that it should be a
self-built dwelling only
and obviously
um there's a difference between or i've
always thought that self build and
custom build will come into the same
bracket
can we specify
one not the other
i think in this case it would be
appropriate
to condition it as a self-build dwelling
because that's what they've applied for
i think custom build
can be um
on a site where they're using modern
methods of construction and things like
that which are also encouraged but i
don't think it's once before members
tonight
[Music]
anyone else have any questions before i
chuck mine in
no
um terry could you pull the picture up
with a little uh star on that you had
please
to my mind there is a property to the
north
when looking at this picture at least uh
to the north and to the south of that
star um you stated on page 19 that you
do not consider that the proposal to be
limited in phil
can you explain to me why
this site between two properties is not
considered limited infill please
so where there is a defined build up
area boundary there's no need for an
assessment of whether something is in
when the physical confines of the
village so as it's outside of the
defined bob it can't be considered
limited to important
essentially yes it's in the open country
side from from our point of view
um because of the substantial weight
that's afforded to the draft the uab and
the ndp
that is extraordinary helpful thank you
very much
um okay
anyone else with any points of
clarification uh in which case we will
move to debate who would like to kick us
off in the debates
anyone anyone counselor jennings you're
going to save me thank you i guess it's
going to be me again um
i think always always with these sort of
things and we've had this experience
that recently is that a lot of the
policies being formed at the moment
um but we do have an obligation
to provide
um self-build
plots and we have got a we have got a
shortfall of them
um
i
it's adjacent to the built-up area
boundary and i
at the moment my inclination is if it
was to be specified i say as a self
build i'm probably more inclined to go
for that away
but
listen to everyone else before i make
any further comment
council mills next please
thanks mr chairman yeah um just
literally concerned about because we we
do like to protect our green belt
um so just a bit concerned all that much
mr chairman um
i'm just being uncomfortable with it
uncomfortable with it but i will listen
to what other people got to say thank
you thank you councilman cancer kendall
thank you um i'm with cancer jennings i
think on this one and it was part of the
point you picked to hear which was this
to me looks a little bit like a limited
infill now i understand that the
explanation was given but for me
we have a commitment to
provide a number of self-built dwellings
and for me this seems to be i think a
limited infill as well
so i i think i'll be following the
officer's recommendation going for grant
thank you very much
council flying
um yeah i mean
i always have two things about these
self builds so pity that the
the the owner and the builders not here
that we can ask certain questions about
how they're going to build the thing um
and as long as it's not a custom build i
don't have that bigger problem with it
the green belt thing is always an issue
for us and
sometimes we we pass them through
sometimes we don't but the other thing
again about this is
they i see they've applied for a an
exemption on on sale payments and
whatever else so we're back to another
situation where there's going to be a
property built within a small community
and no commit and no additional payments
for infrastructure so that's one of the
things i don't like about it
but uh as far as the actual property
itself goes i'm struggling really just
to find out why we should refuse the
officer's recommendation so at the
moment i'm going to do the same with all
the rest and sit on the fence
casakram
thank you thanks jim
yeah um i might be slightly going
against grain on this one um personally
i think we do need to listen to the
community especially going through the
the pain and torture of getting the
neighborhood development plan through
um
we ask them to
be the local voice and they know their
area well and it's not a site the
neighborhood development plan
says they should be building in
it's outside the built-up area boundary
and it's in the green belt
and i don't think
the
one house that will be built against our
need of 81 is very special circumstances
i think we need to make sure these
houses these south building custom built
even though we've got a short fall
need to be built in the right place and
building in the green belt
i don't think it is in the right place
at the moment and one compared to 81
shortfall is not going to make a
significant difference
so um i can't support this application
i'm afraid thank you councillor crump um
council reform
thank you
i think i support what councillor crump
and councillor mills have said i have a
problem with it being in the green belt
and setting a precedent
with that so that's where i am at the
moment
thank you very much
anyone else i'm gonna i've got a
question that has been prompted by a
conversation just now um for points of
clarification shall i do that now or
would you guys like to speak first
i'll go ahead and do that so um if you
may if you don't mind clarifying for me
um the uh parish councillor council
saunders um
talked about a national policy stating
that um we shouldn't be looking to put
self and custom build in sites that
would otherwise not be suitable for
development
is that correct and uh also referred to
the fact that our sap emerged whilst
it's not
um
what is emerging at the moment and
therefore doesn't have full weight um
states that uh we should
avoid green belt for self and custom
build is that correct
yes i think both of those correct
on the first i would say that
national policy as it stands at the
moment
um
identifies greenbelt it says that where
there are um where there is
inappropriate development it can't be
accepted unless under very special
circumstances and and that's what our
report really assesses in our view we
think there is very special
circumstances so
in if if members were inclined to agree
with that it wouldn't prevent them
granting permission
on the second point um the site
allocations plan is a very early stage
of development um it holds very limited
weight in the determination of this
application as members know this is a a
live sort of situation where we have um
a need to meet self and custom build
housing
so although there is an emerging policy
which suggests that there could
be a policy which disallowed development
of self-custom-built housing in the
green belt
that's not where we are at the current
time and and dissuade members from
affording weight to that policy even
though it is necessary for members to
weigh up whether they agree with
officers recommendation about how much
harm there is to the green belt
and whether there are very special
circumstances to to overcome that harm
thank you that's very helpful
um i'll put my pen and two penis worth
in now if i may um i'm going to propose
to re refuse this application
um and i'm the reason for that i'm a
firm believer that green belt should be
protected we have green power policy for
a reason it is national policy as well
as local policy and has been around for
a long long time it's there for a
purpose um it is clear from what we've
just heard that government policy does
state that uh custom and self-built
properties should not go in positions
where otherwise development would be
unsuitable we've also been told tonight
that this proposal is unsuitable in
greenbelt terms and the only reason it's
been put forward is the very special
circumstances are itself and custom
build
so to my mind the very special
circumstances do not hold material
weight
for the reasons given uh that it would
be otherwise unsuitable to build this
property in this location
um uh
and i also give weight albeit not albeit
limited weight to our emerging
sap
uh and that we should not be building
self and custom bills or avoiding as
much as possible anyway self and custom
builds within the green belt um
those are my reasons
if anyone else would like to speak to it
i would be seeking a second debt please
councillor crump um
as you say i've made my feelings no not
already which obviously coincided with
your surprises uh fly echoed by a fly um
but i'm more than happy to second your
proposal mr chairman
thank you very much has anyone else got
anything they would like to say would
anyone like to put a counter proposal
forward
no in that case let's move to a vote so
the proposal is to refuse uh application
21 0 3 7 1 6 o ut lander ellswood common
ellswood could i have a show of hands
for all those
clarifications
my reasons are very solid
but thank you
um the proposal is to refuse the
application for the reason science
stated club please have a show of hands
for those in favor of refusal
unanimous chance
it's not no it's not it's seven chapters
and uh against
one german thank you very much so uh
committee therefore resolves to refuse
application twenty one zero three seven
one six o u t
marvelous um now we are going to have a
quick change over our case officer but
we will carry on nonetheless um so our
next item is uh application 2201179
ful that is oak tree barn ridgeway
lennon lane in afton our presenting
officer stuart flair see stuart as soon
as you're comfortable and set to go
the floor is yours
thank you chairman uh good evening
um
yeah
i'm sorry
thank you thank you everybody um this
proposal seeking full planning
commission for the erection of a part
single and part two-story extension to
an existing dwelling
the application site is to the north of
the village of often in an area of open
countryside the site is to the west of
ridgeway lane as indicated by the black
dot on this plan
uh here we have the submitted existing
and proposed site layout plans
uh the extent of the proposed extension
is shown here in the blue block
um here we see some satellite imagery
denoting the location of the site here
here we now see the existing and
proposed elevational detail for the
south east elevation
this would be the effective uh
frontage when viewed directly from the
street scene
here we see the existing proposed
northwest elevations
we have some photos of the site and its
surroundings here we are still at the
point of the highway looking westwards
towards the application property here
here we are now stood on the green verge
looking northwards
the proposed extension is to is proposed
to be cited here where my cursor is
hovering over
and finally uh here we're still on the
highway again looking directly at the
southeast elevation as existing
officers
consider that this proposal fails to
comply with the development plan
national planning policy and
supplementary planning guidance
uh officers are inclined to agree with
the applicant and consultants who have
commented that the former barn now
converting to a dwelling has achieved a
high standard of design
it's office's view however that the
proposed extension the subject of this
application
um
harms that character of this dwelling in
addition to the surrounding character
around it
um i refer you all to the update sheet
uh for updates uh chairman the
recommendation is to refuse the
application for the reasons on page 28
of your report thank you
sure thank you very much indeed um we
will call our first speaker on this item
who is councillor taylor from afton
parish council
good evening cancer taylor thank you for
your patience
so i think you've probably got an idea
of what's happening now you're going to
have three minutes i'll give you 30
second one before your time is up if you
press the red button in the middle it
should activate and then the floor will
be yours
give it give it another go just to make
sure council reading can you see if it's
red
sorry about this
are we
yes perfect marvelous whenever you're
ready cancer taylor
thank you very much uh i'm speaking uh
in favor of this application
i'm chairman of often parish council i
have read
all the papers concerned with this both
from planning and from the application
and i don't want to talk about the
nitty-gritty of this i'll leave that to
a subsequent speaker but what i would
like to do if i may
is to make four brief points
uh which i hope will help you in making
your decision
one is that often paris council has
very carefully considered this
application and unanimously supports
what it is
uh we've had nine letters of support
from parishioners and no objections now
saying that nine doesn't sound very many
does it um but it's actually a very
small village so it's actually about ten
percent of the adult population
um
and no objections
second point is that
back in 2009
there's a very interesting precedent uh
set
uh with
a very similar situation
it was a new build on a plot in often
and
in the design and access statement
photographic evidence was presented
showing previous
footings
that application was approved
and i think i think the criteria are are
the same the question of the previous
footprint
if you would like it i have the
reference to that application here
uh
i'll give it to you now or later if you
wish
third point is that
the apple the application there's a
son-in-law to mr hyatt wood farm
the jason farm and this extension
uh that's requested lies on what was
uh uh mr heights farmland
i think somebody else is going to say
this but uh this whole family
uh has have been
really very very good stewards of this
land for
over half a century more than that over
80 years probably nearer to a century
and i'll continue to continue to do so
despite the
depredations of hs2 running
very close to this property and indeed
to the farmers property
i think i would like to take the
opportunity to make the point that
i i've been on and off the chairman of
the parish council for about 20 years 30
seconds
and in all that time
uh we've been regularly assured by the
higher authorities
that local voices are important
um i i come here as a local voice and i
ask you therefore please to approve this
application
um and i thank you for your time
perfect well within your time thank you
very much indeed if you could stay
seated for questions members do we have
any questions for cancer taylor please
looks like there are none so in that
case cancer thanks very much for your
time thank you too
we will move to our next speaker who is
mr acres i think and mr wilks have i
pronounced that right
i hope so
good evening and welcome
now
could you tell me who
which of you is which if you don't mind
me asking i'm john acres good evening mr
vegas and this mr works um now mr eggs
are you going to be doing the speaking
and uh our applicants here for questions
is that correct um if well i think you
also wanted to say a few words as well
but shall i start that's fine how do you
want to split the time do you want me to
give you a do you want me to say a
minute and a half each or shall i just
let it flow and i'll give you the third
second warning i hope i'll finish in a
minute to half but a minute and a half
isn't very long but um i'm happy for you
to cut me off what
how long do you need you need a minute
now
yeah
i'll let you know when a minute and a
half is on
[Laughter]
you're good to go so whenever you're
ready i'll press the button i'm rob and
my wife pam we're the applicants and
we've lived in the village for over 30
years my wife all of her life my
father-in-law who owns the farm where
the farm is located has lived there for
over 80 years derek my father-in-law
knocked part of the barn down several
years ago the park
which formed the owl shape in question
as it had become come unsafe the
original footings are still visible
derrick helped us design the l-shaped
part of the barn describing how it used
to look and operate the barn is an
isolated location not in view from any
other properties our nearest neighbours
are family members living a thousand
metres away on the other side of the
hill
recently hs2 constructed a service road
past the barn removing both hedges trees
to widen the road
this has resulted in them taking eight
metres of our garden and leaving the
road just eight meters from the barn
this gravel road services 20 lorries per
day and is expected to remain for at
least five years more before it is
reduced back to its original width and
the hedges trees in our garden can be
replanted we're both country people who
want to preserve the countryside and
encourage wildlife we've planted trees
hedges dug out a pond put up bird boxes
etcetera in one of our bird boxes we
currently have four barn owl chicks
we receive lots of support from local
residents parish council and our ward
member and i hope you feel that you're
able to grant this application for
ourselves our family and the future of
the farm thank you
thank you
you have just over a minute and 45 left
so whenever you're ready thank you good
evening chairman my name is john acres i
represent mr wilkes as his planning
consultant i've already sent through a
written report which i'm sure you've
read so i won't repeat it
in summary i don't share the
professional views or conclusions of the
case officer there is no reference in
the report to the up-to-date policy in
the mppf which is warmly supportive of
reusing buildings in the countryside
such as this and in promoting rural
prosperity
the core strategy makes no reference
whatsoever to barn conversions or
extensions
the officers report relies on generic
policies for landscape and house
extensions both of which have a tenuous
link to this case
the spd on agricultural buildings g7 g8
dates from 2018
but is word for word based on the old
district design guide published in 2001
21 years ago this document
the officer accepts the restored barn
sits on the wider l-shaped footprint
you've seen that on the slides
yet they have argued against an
extension which conforms to that
l-shaped footprint calling it pastiche
they've not applied the evidence which
has been supplied to them
finally the case for refusal is not
because it would offend or prejudice
neighbors they accept no neighbours
would be harmed indeed there are nine
supporters of the scheme
they argue the proposal offends the
building itself
but it is mr wilkes who's rescued the
building and restored it and without his
time and effort
perseverance the barn simply wouldn't be
there
so i urge you
that mr wilkes needs to be commended not
condemned for his efforts to restore the
bomb to its original footprint and i
would urge you to grant him consent to
enable him to finish off the work
thank you i was about to ask you to sign
off then and you were just about to i
apologize for interrupting you there
that's dead on three minutes um members
do we have any questions for either our
applicant or our agent
no
in that case gentlemen thank you very
much for your time and your contribution
this evening and thanks for your
patience
if you don't mind uh mrake is pressing
the button in the middle as well just to
turn that microphone off otherwise it'll
pick up all sorts of feedback thank you
very much indeed
okay members points of clarification to
our officers would anyone like a point
clarify
i'm so sorry i forgot you were here i'm
sorry cancer adam
i
that's embarrassing
it is you were hiding at the back you
should have come forward a bit earlier
um so cancer adam you know the drill
you've got five minutes 30 second
warning whenever you're ready to
thank you very much and thank you
committee um i'm fully supportive of
this um and
i think that the thing that comes to
mind most is how unique this case is um
the the reasoning that the officers put
forward would in other cases i'm sure be
perfectly reasonable in line with our
with our um
core strategy um however this is so much
different and more nuanced than i think
that gives credit for really um the main
reasons that um highlight in the report
are based on landscape being the sort of
key reason for uh recommending refusal
um
what i think is
hard to
um realize without sort of going to the
site and seeing the pictures is the the
foundations that are
to to this existing l shape are there in
the ground when um it was being
renovated before you could see where
this part of the building used to go uh
it only came down because of um as as
the applicant said sort of dilapidation
and safety if um but for a few years
they'd put the class q in before it
would be there as part of the
site as it is anyway um
in reality i mean i i can
understand the the concern around these
but um in terms of cs5 and cs9 i think
the the layout and the orientation have
been driven by what the original uh
construction was
it's not like it's not that they're
trying to sort of push it beyond uh what
they think is reasonable or what we
would think is reasonable they're being
driven by what was there um
as the applicant said they've been in
the in the village for years and um
stewards of the land for
generations now um and that's what's
pushed them to have this design um
with that in mind the design is
specifically
um minded to be sensitive to the
landscape similar to how it originally
would have been in its original form
um that's in terms of the materials used
and orientation and arrangement
um and how that's been um formulated
within the design is also sensitive to
the work that the applicant's done in
terms of uh renovating the existing um
building which uh it's you know i've
seen a
nick and really good quality i think
this would complement that incredibly
well um as as part of that
um
ultimately um
taking into account the the sort of
extension and development
being
part of the original structure i think
we can justify it very strongly under
those
landscape aspects of our core strategy
because it does seek to enhance the site
um
in in a way that was restoring it to his
original state effectively um
[Music]
and
yeah it's more of a reinstatement i'd
say than an extension and i think that's
very critical and again makes this very
unique and nuanced in compared to um
what we might ordinarily see from a
class queue that was looking for an
extension that's certainly not what's
being looked at here um i think the
the the other speakers said said it very
well that you know this has got
community support um these are people
who care for the land in the landscape
it is a landscape which is being torn up
in other senses by sort hs2 and i think
although that's not what's in front of
us here it's worth bearing in mind that
we have got people who really are
sensitive to to what the landscape looks
like and how it goes uh will be going in
into the generations to to come so i
really do urge the committee to support
this uh i think there's perfectly good
reasons under our core strategy to do
that thank you very much
azram thank you very much indeed members
do have any questions for
our war member
no in that case cancer thank you for
your time and your contribution and i
apologize but i almost overlooked you
this time members we're going to get a
point of clarification would anyone like
any points clarified
casamills
thanks michelle um
um
the extension i mean
we're talking about going the over the
old footings
of something that was
that was already there what what i'm a
bit con confused over there is there is
there or isn't the uh original footings
there of a of a building of some sort
thank you councillor um it's my
understanding based on the speakers
we've heard tonight in in addition it's
minus telling that there are footings
there from the previous structures in
agricultural use that were historically
on site
i can't verify but i've no evidence for
the country to say this proposed
extension for residential use goes
beyond or is within that remit but it's
my understanding that there are footings
on site
um and that it was in approximately this
orientation
thank you
council jennings
just a bit of clarification on this
i'm presuming the l-shaped bit which got
knocked down because it was dilapidated
if that was that
if they had gone for class q
because it was dilapidated it wouldn't
have got class q
yes councillor jennings that's entirely
right
there
is a requirement for a class q
conversion for the building to be um
substantial and structurally sound
and for the um
for it to be a conversion rather than a
rebuild of a building
just to confirm
there are no pd rights i presume they
were taken away when
the class q was given
yeah class q doesn't confer any pd
rights
anyone else with any questions
i have one am i right in thinking that
uh on the whole we um
when we're looking at extensions we
should be considering them as
subservient to the dwelling itself
is that right is that for our assessment
that would be a fair assessment but that
would that estimation would be based on
core strategy policies that quoted in
your report and also supplementary
planning guidance in addition
marvelous thank you while we're going to
debate would you mind bringing up
pictures of the um of the proposal so uh
sort of elevations marvelous thank you
okay unless anyone else has any
questions for uh clarifying we will move
into the debate is this clarification
council dixon sorry chairman just uh
spotting the original uh
history here uh application 14.
i just wondered if there's any evidence
on there
of the existence of
the extension that is now
requested or whether it had already been
demolished by 2014 some
eight years ago
yeah i can confirm it is in fact
referred to at the top of page 27 and
thereafter that the um the structure was
present and it was demolished sometime
in
up until the 1990s it says it was on
site so it would have would have been
gone by the time those uh applications
are under consideration
okay last chance for points for
clarification
and hopefully no one's going to come up
with one later let's move to the debate
who would like to kick us off
can scandal was that a hand up
uh please now
thank you okay
um
i've got a great deal simply for the
applicant and i understand entirely
where the parish is coming from on this
and it's always heartening to see um an
application come forward with support
from the parish council and the
community i think my my key concern is
i've come to the conclusion in the
paperwork here and it's to it's due with
the wording of um
introducing built form which is not
visually harmonious or subservient to
the dwelling i find this it's not
subservient to the original dwelling and
so for that reason i'm not necessarily
against the idea of an extension to this
building at all
just not necessarily this proposal
so with that in mind i'm going to i'm
going to follow the officer's
recommendation to refuse
is that a proposal it can be yes it is
it is thank you very much council
jennings
i think probably i'm i'm thinking along
the same lines i mean i think they've
done a great job on the renovation um
but
the fact that the old l shape
wasn't
was demolished because it was
dilapidated so if they had to do that
because they they wouldn't have got the
house in the first place or the the barn
conversion in the first place um
i do believe that and i have a lot of
sympathy for them for the disruption
i've had to go through with hs2
um
i'm sorry i've been really looking at
ways to sort of to go in favor of this
but i'm i'm struggling on
material planning reasons
and
the fact that the extension would be so
large
again
it's a problem
and if it was smaller i would certainly
be more inclined to
to go in that direction um
i therefore regrettably second the
motion um council jennings thank you
very much for that i'm just going to
point out again that um uh on top of
page
27 it does say in 1990 it was knocked
down so it wasn't demolished to get the
class q planning permission i just want
to clarify that
um
before we move on uh counselor evan
please
uh thank you chair oh it worked
um
uh the
yeah the design itself doesn't to my
mind cause any harm it's standing on the
same footprint doesn't cause any harm i
i though i am then minded still
alongside counselor kendall and jennings
that the size is probably the problem
here
for me so i'm gonna have to follow suit
i think
okay cancer fleming
yeah i really like to see these old
buildings preserved and they've
obviously done a good job with phase one
of this um i've
no real objections to them extending it
and
i think it's just this extension i have
a problem with
um so i think that
i need to go away and have a look at it
and come back with something else
but on this particular
extension i'd have to go along with
officer's recommendation
okay thank you very much
before we move to a vote does anyone
else like say anything council mills
thank you mr chairman i'm probably
against everybody else here um
i can't see what he does any harm you
know visual harm or
any harm whatsoever so uh
i'll be quite happy with it yes it is it
is a large extension but i can't say
it's do any visual harm or any harm or
stop mr chairman thank you
council foreman
thank you chair um i'm thinking along
the lines of councillor mills and i also
think we should be taking into account
the parish council and all the residents
that are happy to support this and
they're the ones that are going to have
to be living with it and around it so
i'm saving councillor mills
version
can i send you seraphim
yes um
i'm in favour of this i think it's well
designed it's not exceeding the existing
footprint that was there
um there is no objections within the
village it has board member parish and
resident
support and
i i don't have any reason to go
against
refusing this
i would
go with grant
thank you
okay thank you very much anyone else
want to say anything
for the sake of it i'll check mine
because it seems that everyone else has
had a crack at this one as well um
i'm going to be agreeing with cancer
kendall and cancer jennings and a number
of other members um
i've got no particular issue with the
suggestion that an extension could go on
this property
my view is that it almost doubles the
footprint of of the the existing
domestic
home um and therefore could not be
considered to be subservient to it um
whilst i appreciate the fact that
footings clearly show that there was a
building there
um it's not been there for 30 years that
we know of
and also at the time it would have been
agricultural
not domestic not residential
very different rules applied to each one
we have to apply the rules as it is now
which is a domestic dwelling not as an
agricultural one
so
i don't
think that the fact that footings were
there uh as agricultural fits well with
the fact that it is now domestic
dwelling so um
on that basis i'm going to be uh going
with the officer's recommendation uh as
it's been put
does anyone else want to say anything
before we move to a vote
no let's move to a vote so the proposal
is to refuse in line with the officer
recommendation could have a show of
hands for those in favor of refusal
that's six german and those against
that's three german committee therefore
resolves to refuse application twenty
two zero one one seven nine ful oak tree
farm and ridgeway lane in often um for
the reasons given
i don't believe we have any urgent
business
in which in which case um it leaves me
to thank you all for your time and
contribution the same for members of the
public that have been here and of course
our officers as well we will see you in
two weeks time thank you very much
you